[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen ihr euch
meine damen nennt im neuen video werde
das bereits im titel eingeblendet und
zwar wenn ihr eine wunderschöne ist
kleines paket angekommen was ich direkt
fallen gelassen habe und fast dass hier
das hier meine damen und herren alle
unter euch die den zettel nicht lesen
können sind meine neuen airports büro
ich bin einfach reichen nicht mehr lange
wenn jemand dieses paket ist heute
morgen bei mir in der post an und das
allererste was der prognose zu mir sagt
ist ausweis und ich solle doch jetzt
meinen ausweis bei der auffassung nach
braucht man dann aus weil es nur wenn
man alkohol kaufen will oder einen film
über 18
aber gut ich wollte auf jeden fall
direkt mal auf weiß sehen allerdings hat
er mir dann dieses wunderschöne auch
schon auf mit ob wir sind halt wirklich
entweder so aus dem fenster oder wie ein
fön aber alles andere als die realität
allerdings gemeinsam mal aus und zwar
zieht man sich krieges nicht mehr in die
verpackung auch zu machen
so mache ich papa kommen auch ich habe
mir diese erste eigentlich nur bestellt
weil ich vor einigen wochen auf einige
airports promis reagiert habe und dann
habe ich euch gesagt hey wenn das video
100000 like satz dann bestelle ich mir
die und das ist video hat 100.000 likes
erreicht von daher habe ich mit dieser
300 euro teuren kopfhörer jetzt
tatsächlich bestellt und die sind heute
angekommen und das erstmals vertreter
mit ganz viel platz zum leben
das brauchen wir allerdings nicht
sondern wir kümmern uns um das was hier
drin es entstand das hier
[Musik]
nochmal das sind die airports keine
gravierenden schreiben lassen
die saison hat komisches los also sehen
diese kopfhörer aus habt ihr euch auch
schon in diesem video gezeigt wo ich auf
mich reagiert habe ich stecke jetzt
einfach mal ins tor
oh gott ich höre ich hab ich gesagt ich
habe fast gar nichts mehr also erstmal
zeige ich euch was ich ihn halt erstmal
zeige ich euch was sich hier noch so
alles in diesem paket befindet und zwar
halt einmal das paket an sich ganz viel
verpackung das ca
denn hier selbstverständlich noch ein
ladekabel für das ding ganz viel
papierkram und halt diese komische
verpackung wenn man die teile reinpacken
kann aber so sehen wir jetzt aus ich
verbinde mit meinem handy und ich mache
jetzt einfach mal unseren podcast an
also den von sander ist tatsächlich
jetzt gerade eine neue folge online
gegangen als und in der infobox medien
auf den link klicken und euch die neue
folge die koffer um ein kompass was die
teilweise sich kein anderes als die
ersten der prozessor kirche wenn sie
dort nur ein podcast an gemacht aber ich
mache jetzt einfach nur sie kann hierbei
ja ja ok die kopfhörer sind tatsächlich
gar nicht wo mein gott wenn man die raus
sind das ist so wie wenn man sich so die
ohren zuhält wenn man die kopfhörer drin
hat das liegt natürlich auch an diesem
unfassbar hessischen aufsetzen oder
schon ein bisschen und schmalz von mir
hier dran so werden die post hat
zwangsläufig aussehen wenn man die jeden
tag drin als also hier auch nochmal der
vergleich von den neuen airports pro mit
den alten r potsdam die verpackung ist
oder als verpackung aber dieses case ist
auf jeden fall größer wenn wir die
abräumer auspacken und hier hinlegen und
einmal direkt mit den alten airports
nebeneinander vergleichen sehen wir auch
direkt schon hier die sind billiger aber
dafür kürzer also der stil ist irgendwie
kürze hier seht ihr die direkt
nebeneinander bin ganz ehrlich ich finde
die alten schöner vom design
ich habe was ich habe links den alten
drin und ich kann trotzdem musik hören
ich meine mit viel lack ich denke bei
solchen sachen halt immer was könnte ich
sonst von dem geld kaufen dass das
produkt kostet und von 300 euro könnte
ich mir hundert dollar kaufen
ja ich würde die döner nehmen also ich
meine klar die kopfhörer sind nice und
die haben auf jeden fall der bessere
qualität als die alte airports aber ich
hasse halt dieses in ihr kann ist für
mich das gesuch penetriert immer aber
selbst wenn ich sie für mich bestellt
hätte ich hätte die safe zurückgeschickt
aber ich habe sehr für euch gestellt
werden als leicht geknackt
deswegen hab ich die bestellte dass ihr
gewinnen könnte das wahnsinnig über
jedes messer aber ich bin trotzdem
schärfer
meine sehr verehrten kuscheln kuscheln
bisschen ich mache jetzt erstmal wieder
zusammen
und ich glaube ich mache ja nochmal
zauberberg in slate ich habe sauber
machen gerade aus versehen dieses
komische die schaumstoff gummi dinge
abgezogen
wir sind halt unbedingt und co lässt aus
dieser getröte dass sie das wirklich aus
wie dieses dick von mario frühe diagnose
wieder zusammen die verpackung ja das
tut mir leid dass ich die ein bisschen
kaputt gemacht haben mit der
gruppierungen aufgestiegen wäre das
stinkt ich will halt einfach dass ihr
die nicht verkauft so ich habe die
vertrauen und euro bestellt ist einer
von euch die haben kann also gar kein
wort dass die einer gegründet ich denke
wir zukünftig beliebig gegenüber steve
lukather toto riina und deswegen werden
wir auf jeden fall noch habt diese
herford pro hier zu gewinnen
dann folgt mir gerne auf instagram ich
heiße dort laser luca und ein neues foto
das habe ich soeben hochgeladen das
müsst ihr einfach nur licon und unter
allen leuten das foto geleitet haben und
die mir auf instagram folgen verlose ich
dann diese erfolgsprojekt das
gewinnspiel gerne auf youtube machen
allerdings kann man auf youtube sehr
schwer leute kontaktieren die irgendwie
kommentiert haben und man kann sich auch
genau so nennen die andere user das ist
auf instagram bisschen leichter deswegen
folgt mir auf instagram und vielleicht
ein neues foto wenn ihr diese r post pro
wald bei euch im postkasten sehen
wollten sich an der stelle des heutigen
wir jetzt auch beenden eine liebe
freunde ich weiß es seit heute ein
bisschen ein kurzes video kommt man da
draußen und da stehen die menge flaschen
und eine flasche steht auch hier noch
bitten alles klar durch das heutige
video gefallen lassen auf jeden fall
gerne einen daumen hoch oder daumen
jetzt glaube ich hoffe mein kopf ist
voll mit blut ich das wieder gefallen
das auf jeden fall gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video aus schreibt mir
gerne
die kommentare was ihr für ein handy
habt konzentration oft pistole des
workshops sixties touch the essence of
the community mascis all in the
detention noch waren aufgebaut die
beiden tänzerinnen vis á vis autos und
damit teil
[Musik]